is Nutella a huge fear food for you I
hear about in my comment section all the
time you love Nutella but you're scared
to eat it because if you start you just
won't stop but if you want to knock
Nutella off of its pedestal you have to
allow yourself to eat it unconditionally
without guilt or shame so I'm going to
show you how to turn your beloved
Nutella into the ultimate hunger
crushing combo so you can have your
favorite breakfast pal more often
without the inevitable crash if you guys
are new here my Hunger crushing combo is
a non-diet approach to building balanced
meals and snacks so rather than removing
the food that you love we just focus on
adding in some Fiber protein and healthy
fats exhibit a these Nutella protein
balls to a food processor add 1 cup of
oats half a cup of chocolate protein
powder 1/4 cup of alond butter 1/4 cup
of Nutella yummy 1/4 cup of flax 1/4 cup
of hemp a splash of vanilla and enough
liquid to process it smooth we've got
fiber protein and healthy fats to keep
us satiated and stabilize our blood
sugars and we got the fun Factor coming
in hot with our beloved Nutella add
don't restrict save this video and let
me know in the comments what food you'd
like me to turn into a hunger crushion
combo